Savannah how is that hair and makeup
gone we're all doing our best Savannah
Guthrie out here doing her own glam for
the Today Show amid a global pandemic
now we're doing it ourselves and we're
just doing the best we can you know no
doubt the TV anchor is juggling a lot
right now which may explain why she felt
the need to respond to a Twitter user
who criticized her look on Monday the
follower tweeted Savannah directly
asking come on with what they pay you
can't you afford a hairstylist I love
the natural unkempt look but it's
distracting on NBC national news
Savannah replied but kept it classy even
taking a dig at herself simply writing
we are all doing our own hair and makeup
during the pandemic and yes it shows one
of the best perks of working at the
Today Show and I know Hoda will agree
because we both spent many many years
and local news doing our own hair and
makeup and yes speak for themselves
if you go back and look at the tapes
with our crazy hair yeah not great but
it could be worse yeah the day Savannah
replied to the critique was also the
same day she reunited with fellow Today
anchor Al Roker for a socially distant
outdoor broadcast I told you I was
bringing the fun well here's the fun
right here will you believe this Oh
Roker yeah we have been reunited we're
kissing the outdoor setting was a change
for Savannah who's been broadcasting
live from her home in upstate New York
while she's quarantined amid the corona
virus pandemic et spoke with the anchor
via video chat in April and she opened
up about balancing motherhood with
working from home I've got my whole
family we live a couple hours outside
the city right now and so it's a little
trickier for me to come into the studio
every single day so they set up this
basement studio which i think is pretty
cool and that way I can listen to my
kids footsteps on the ceiling and then
go be a mom right after the show
[Music]